I'll begin with bronze medal honors and
this year's year goes to Kevin her on
for his film hex pocket first off I
would just like to thank everybody for
watching my pretty much my whole film
there even though I didn't win gold so
I'm really excited it's always a
blessing to hear everyone else laughs
any rate I have a cheat sheet here I
guess I'll continue the tradition by
first thanking the Academy because
without you guys I wouldn't have this
opportunity to be here and enjoy all
these great things and great moments and
made all these other wonderful animators
and people and you know be blessed with
this great opportunity so thank you for
that next I'd like to thank my family
for the financial and encouragement and
support they've always given me ever
since I was young because I wouldn't be
able to pursue animation if it wasn't
without without them so next I like to
thank the faculty I got quite a few so
i'm going to say their first names Jim
John Jeremy Paul and Billy because
without their help and guidance it would
have been a very poor film to be honest
and something completely different I'd
like to thank my composure and sound
designer Carlos Martin and Yan tan
without their talents in the audio
department the film would just be
something else they really raised it to
another level so I'm very grateful for
them I'd like to thank my girlfriend
Tiffany Chelle cuz she was my emotional
crutch through most of ringling and it
been very hard without her sorry trying
to hold back my man tears um
finally uh I like to just thank god cuz
um ah sir I like to thank god cuz
without him like every step along this
way and along this journey has been a
blessing and although with some parts
you know as a little oh you know I
didn't get this i didn't get that there
were always blessings in disguise that
led me here so thanks everybody i gotta
go